Daniel Nicola came to the UK as an
international student from Albania and
has gone on to forge a successful career
in Britain I moved to the UK when I was
20 years old I studied English as
foreign language then Creative Media
production and Film Production
in London and then I moved into the
Midlands to work for a manufacturer and
I head of the marketing team for the
company but the government says it wants
to cut down the number of people able to
come here people just like Daniel
focusing on International students on
this very issue brings me back to 2016
where some of the universities in the UK
started struggling financially because
International students were feeling
unwelcomed and move into other countries
and this although you may be doing good
feels to me like it's creating a similar
sense so you're part of your community
you're contributing to your community
you're earning money and you're spending
money in the economy you'd think you'd
be the last person who the government
would want to prevent coming here I
suspect so we should be encouraged
early in the week numbers revealed net
migration had topped six hundred
thousand the Home Secretary sawella
bravman wants that reduced by as much as
half a million speaking on Sky News the
health secretary says it can be done
well the Home Secretary is absolutely
right on the need to bring the numbers
down and the Prime Minister reaffirmed
his commitment to bringing the overall
numbers down I think there's a
distinction to draw between for example
some of the abuse of student Roots
people coming in on a student visa and
then changing looking at the number of
dependents
neighbor says it also has a plan to
reduce migration numbers saying work
visas should come with a time limit
arguing that would encourage companies
to take on and train British workers
instead what this is is about saying to
firms we you should be investing in the
workforce that you've got on the
potential future workers by investing in
their skills and retraining
opportunities rather than pulling the
lever of going straight to International
Recruitment and undercutting the wages
by cutting those wages by 20 we don't
think that is fair
migration is a thorny divisive intensely
political subject and both labor and the
conservatives say they're offering up
workable Solutions the problem is
experts in this field are skeptical
reducing net migration on the scale the
government's proposing could have huge
implications for the economy how do you
bring in the immigration down well you
have two choices you either just ban
immigration that will cause Devastation
in the Health Service or you I don't
know come up with our Workforce plan for
the National Health Service you pay
social care workers better and you
actually create the circumstance in
which more domestic workers want to work
in that sector
The Balancing Act here reducing
migration numbers without crippling the
economy set against the demands from
voters as an election draws closer Nick
Martin Sky News Westminster